dans les avantages c'est donner un
pouvoir au peuple mais sans trop tomber
dans le populisme pour moi initiative
est le référendum
ça sert à rééquilibrer finalement des
lois qui serait en outre pas droit tout
repas gauche si je veux dire et c'est là
que vient le référendum est l'initiative
ça donne la voix aussi à 10,1 des
préoccupations que peut-être les
parlementaires ne met pas en avant et ça
c'est quelque chose d'utile pour les
minorités maintenant les désavantages
c'est sûr que à force de trop voté dans
l'année on a un taux de rotation qui est
bas entre 45 et 50% pour chaque votation
rarement puce quasiment jamais et puis
ce sont aussi des instruments qui pour
finir sont utilisés par tous les partis
pour mettre en avant leurs propres
programmes et donner une sorte d'agenda
à leurs préoccupations
ce qui est une bonne chose mais qui est
peut-être aussi parfois moins adéquat se
dire comme vous dites pour utilisé par
les partis politiques ça veut dire que
il utilise pour faire parler d'eux
pourquoi un peu occupé le devant de la
scène médiatique
bah si je prends à l'année prochaine
2010 neuf années électorales en suisse
quasiment tous les partis ont lancé
l'initiative afin de mettre leurs
thématiques en avant mais pour qu'on
puisse parler de donc je dis toujours il
ya livré l efo ces initiatives ya celle
qu'on lance pour lancer parce qu'il faut
faire le débat pour le débat sur vos
propres valeurs à nos propres
agenda et puis à celles qui sont
peut-être parfois précise technique qui
servent à rééquilibrer certaines choses
est ce que le danger ce n'est pas le
populisme
vous savez en suisse c'est une bonne
question je dirai oui et non parce que
d'un côté en suisse tous les partis y
siègent au gouvernement et nous avons la
proportionnelle au parlement donc on
pourrait croire que finalement la moins
besoin d'opposition populiste parfois
pour se faire entendre et en même temps
nous avons un score de 30% pour notre
extrême droite anne donc on voit que est
qu'ils utilisent souvent larmes de
l'initiative et du référendum et eux
c'est souvent du populisme donc moi
j'aime tout cas je ne sacrifierai pas
nos droits citoyens parce qu'il ya un
risque de populisme pour moi aujourd'hui
ça amène vraiment un réquilibrage une
correction à des lois et un parlement
qui parfois gris rétro dans un sens ou
dans l'autre
et oui ça peut servir le populisme mais
c'est un dommage collatéral je pense
qu'il faut pouvoir supporter et qu'on
supporte encore en suisse et l'autre des
avantages c'est qu'évidemment c'est pas
l'image d'épinal ses droits populaires
parce que pour pouvoir lancer par
exemple initiative ses cent mille
signatures en 18 mois et un référendum
c'est cinquante mille signatures en 100
jours
eh bien il faut tu tenant même une
organisation de l'argent et c'est pas un
citoyen qui se lèvent le matin des
élections si l'ancien initiative ou un
référendum
est ce que si l avantage c'est que
quelle que soit la question ça lance ou
moins débat ce qui est sûr c'est que
quand vous lancez initiative ou un
référendum si vous aboutissez vous
obtenez des signatures et qu'on passe
devant le peuple
même si le peuple refuse ce qui est
proposé et c'est très souvent le cas en
fait très peu d'initiatives et très peu
de référendums sont acceptées par le
pape une fois que les signatures sont
réunis eh bien ça permet quand même
selon le score que fait cette initiative
ou ce référendum
ça permet aussi et ça doit même
hors cet effet que le parlement se
disent tiens là il ya eu 40 % peut-être
de résultats ça veut dire qu'on doit
quand même faire attention et on doit
proposer quelque chose qui est quand
même dans le sens même si on n'a pas
obtenu
enfin si le peuple n'a pas voulu
l'initiative et référendum mais c'est un
signal très fort pour les politiques
je pense notamment au no billag qui a eu
lieu donc en début d'année ça a donné
lieu à un débat sur pourquoi une
redevance et pour quelle télévision
publique
il est certain qu'en politique il est
très rare mais c'est comme partout que
ce soit ceux qui sont concernés qui
veulent changer là ni mobilisme de fait
dans tous les domaines donc quand il
faut secouer le cocotier et ben c'est ça
vient très régulièrement du pop qui met
en avant des thématiques que nous ne ne
saisirions pas peut-être donc c'est une
bonne chose là aussi il y aurait pas ça
ça vous manquerez en fait
ahmed c'est inimaginable en suisse qui
est passé droits populaires ça fait
partie de notre adn
et ça fait surtout partie d'un tout quoi
vraiment de quelque chose de ciseler
notre démocratie est quelque chose
d'équilibré en cliquant ton les communes
au niveau fédéral ces droits populaires
ça fait vraiment partie d'un tout et je
pense que supprimer ces droits donnerait
beaucoup trop de pouvoir au parlement et
au gouvernement et je pense c'est une
bonne chose que le peuple ait son mot à
dire même si quelquefois on voit une
suisse morcelé avec les francophones
d'un côté les alémaniques de l'autre
mais avec ou sans initiative avec ou
sans droits populaires la suisse
resterait morcelé et ce qui rend ce qui
nous rend parfois clivé en suisse c'est
pas tellement l'initiative est les
référendums on constate dans ces moments
là une différence de sensibilité qui
n'est pas de l'ordre de la suisse
romande est de la suisse alémanique
comme on a longtemps cru mais entre les
villes et les campagnes ce sont des
sensibilités ville campagne qui votent
très différemment sur pratiquement tous
les sujets donc c'est pas une histoire
de langue c'est pas une histoire
géographique c'est plutôt vraiment le
clivage
ville campagne et il faut nous on a
appris à vivre quand je dis nous c'est
les minoritaires puisque je suis de la
suisse romande est de gauche ça fait
deux minorités en suisse et bien on a
appris à vivre
même quand on perd même si on perd on
doit admettre ben voilà il ya eu un
effet il ya une majorité et inversément
d'ailleurs quand tu vois là tout d'un
coup par miracle les suisses romands
amène une thématique peut-être qu'il
aurait plus sensible que la suisse
allemande si sa façon ils doivent aussi
en tenir compte